like I always say in my videos look and
think for yourself does this Stone
structure appear to be a purely geologic
feature consisting of naturally stacked
Boulders that happen to be aligned in a
perfectly straight fashion or is it
possible that this is an ancient
man-made wall comprising of massive
polygonal stone blocks and that is a
real question is this completely natural
or is this man-made or could it be a
combination of both what you're seeing
here is being referred to as the sage
wall and is located in the remote
mountainous Wilderness in the state of
Montana it is some 275 feet long or 84
meters and up to 24 feet or seven and a
half meters in height and let's be real
the secluded Woods of Montana surrounded
by 400 year old pine trees is among the
Lesser likelier places where we would
expect to find remnants of a long-lost
ancient civilization especially one that
would have had such sophisticated
stonework capabilities
now if you're wondering how you've never
seen or heard of this place before it's
because this is on private property
which is why it is virtually unknown to
the scientific Community as the couple
who own the land themselves were unaware
of this Wall's existence for years as it
is located on the side of a mountain and
was previously consumed with Fallen
trees and heavy foliage that had covered
most of it for hundreds and more likely
many thousands of years leaving this
distinguished wall-like structure barely
discernible especially with so few
people ever having stepped foot near it
in fact it is still completely invisible
from satellite imagery on Google Earth
however with the area around the wall
now cleared we can easily observe its
stunning resemblance to what many
consider to be one of the more bizarre
enigmas involving the topic of lost
ancient human civilizations which is the
existing polygonal stonework that is
found on multiple continents and across
vast oceans around the world whether it
be the astonishing megalithic walls
found throughout Peru and South America
this year's size and precision of which
boggles the mind or the examples found
on the other side of the world in Egypt
as I've shared in Prior videos however
many people are often surprised to learn
that ancient polygonal stone walls can
be found in multiple countries
throughout Europe including Greece Italy
and even turkey these ruins are truly
remarkable yet they receive so little
attention compared to the more notable
ancient European attractions found in
Roman Athens that we certainly all
recognize but I must also mention that
virtually everyone is taken by surprise
when they learn that these ancient
similarities can be found as far away as
Easter Island and even Japan pretty
remarkable to see these unique
similarities across so many vastly
different places on Earth
so the big question becomes is the sage
wall in Montana a relic of a long-lost
ancient civilization or simply a
uniquely natural geological feature or
perhaps like I just mentioned a moment
ago could it be a combination of both
perhaps mostly natural but geoengineered
and enhanced by humans at some point in
the distant past now from what research
I've gathered the scientific explanation
for a formation such as this is that it
is an eroded magmatic Dyke that was
created through volcanic processes when
Rising magma fills into fractures within
older Stone Bedrock which then cools and
solidifies leaving behind a wall-like
feature as we can see in these various
examples and over time erosion creates
cracks and fissures in the stone such as
what we see at the sage wall I took it
upon myself to scour the internet to
find other examples of magmatic dyke
formations and it's incredible to
observe the nature of how things come to
form in such uncommon ways but but I
must say that as impressive as these
examples are there is nothing about them
that gives me any type of feeling or
inclination that they are man-made or
anything other than natural however
that's just not the same Vibe or feeling
I get when I first look at the sage wall
as none of the other examples look quite
as distinctive as this mainly the nature
of how the stones appear purposely
pieced and stacked together and with
such alignment whereas other known
geologic dikes certainly have cracks and
fractures yet they simply do not share
the same resemblance and what makes the
sage wall even more interesting is how
much it differentiates itself from the
surrounding area as seen from Drone
footage the wooded mountainous area is
covered in Boulders a boulder baffle
lift as it's called and is said to be 75
million years old but then there's this
bizarre perfectly straight lined wall
which is a standout to say the least now
speaking of the area surrounding this
wall I've come to learn that there are
many other Incredible or rather
perplexing Stone anomalies not far away
from here whether it be the remarkable
way in which Boulders are stacked in a
dolman-like appearance assembled as if a
table or portal is somehow described and
although I am not suggesting that these
various examples I'm showing you here
are man-made as I can imagine that over
the course of vast lengths of time
through erosion and earthquakes Boulders
will fall down off cliffs and hillsides
and come to rest in ways that would
otherwise seem deliberate or artificial
however I have to say that I am quite
surprised at just how remarkable some of
the stone features in this area are most
of which very few people have ever
documented but if you Google search
Montana megaliths you will come across
many fascinating examples of Nature's
geological wonders in this region that
are just now starting to get more
attention but with that said let's go
back to the sage wall besides its
remarkably straight-lined fashion
observe how the cracks and fissures that
make up these Boulders often do not
continue from one block to the other it
gives an untrained eye the impression
that these Stones were stacked and
pieced together in a puzzle-like
structure and just steps away from the
main wall there are other smaller blocks
that appear to be cut and aligned with
each other again I cannot definitively
say one way or the other as to whether
these Stones were actually cut or how
they were formed and came to look as
they do now I'm just saying that the gut
impression I have when I first see this
site is that it must surely be man-made
or if nothing else geoengineered and
crafted from The Boulders that naturally
make up this area but if all of what
you've seen so far isn't intriguing
enough the next few things you're going
to see will likely surprise you
first notice these cup like marks found
on stones in the vicinity of the sage
wall and notice how perfectly
symmetrical some of them are someone
please explain how on Earth they could
be totally natural in fact they seem to
be something that was used for
sharpening tools or perhaps food
processing whatever their purpose was
I'm not so sure that they were formed
through erosion which is why I must
point out that very similar examples can
be found in ancient stonework on the
other side of the world including
Scotland and even as far away as
Azerbaijan which is located along the
Caspian Sea and although these cut marks
are certainly not conclusive evidence of
some ancient connection across the
continents it does seem reasonable to
say that humans perhaps the Native
Americans had utilized this site in the
past at least to some capacity I mean
look at the more cut-like marks found at
this site was this used for Tool
Sharpening whatever their purpose was
they didn't seem to be carved out and
not some form of erosion now before I
show you something that I consider to be
even more interesting and raises deeper
questions about this site potentially
being a long-lost ancient ruin I must
first give a huge shout out to my buddy
Mike Collins of the wandering wolf
YouTube channel he has visited this site
personally on multiple occasions now and
has sent me these incredible photos of
the sage wall I've only shown you a
small fraction of all the images and
video that he's taken of this site
including incredible Drone footage which
is why I highly recommend that you go
subscribe to his Channel right now in
fact he's currently traveling in the
field and is visiting other sites that
I've never seen or heard of before now
with that said let me show you what else
he documented at the sage wall that I
find to be unbelievably fascinating and
racist thought-provoking ideas about
what's possible for this site as I've
shared in past videos these nub-like
features found in ancient stonework
across the world are something that I
and many others consider to be evidence
that ancient humans were traversing the
oceans and continents long before was
ever thought to be possible some will
say that these Nubs are nothing more
than lifting bosses but what's odd is
that most of the stones don't have them
so regardless of whatever their true
purpose was they are indeed a similarity
that coincidentally are found on Ancient
stonework around the world so I have to
say that I find it quite interesting
that similar examples of these same
parabolically shaped Stone Nubs are also
found at the sage wall and in multiple
different locations throughout the
structure not just one fluke little
example that you might just dismiss as a
unique erosion feature in fact one of
the Nubs even appears to be balancing
that entire Stone dolman-like structure
upright that I showed you earlier notice
how it's centered at its base and
without it it seems that the whole thing
would topple over leave a comment on
whether you think that this is nothing
more than a natural fluke or if you
think that these various Nubs were
created with purpose and intention but
when I see examples of these Nubs as
well as the cup like cutouts and other
unique cuts into the the stone as I just
shared a moment ago it makes me lean
towards that this site is not solely a
natural anomaly and that we may very
well be looking at evidence that ancient
humans had altered this site to what it
is now but to what extent is indeed a
mystery I mean did they actually
construct this wall to make it look as
as it does now that I do not know and
and that is why I insist that this
fascinating site must be studied by
experts they should lidar and use ground
penetrating radar at this site to see
what melee hidden down below and they
should also take 3D scans of the stones
to establish if there's any evidence
that they've been cut and they should
also collect organic material from
underneath this walls Foundation stones
to be analyzed to potentially date its
age and if nothing else if everything
we've seen in this video is totally
natural then it seems to me that it's a
fantastic opportunity for people to
learn something new and share knowledge
of Nature's wonders with the masses
which is why I also encourage you to go
and visit this site yourself which is
easily accessible as it's only an hour
outside of Bozeman Montana which makes
it far more available and affordable to
travel to compared to places such as
Peru or Egypt that so many desire to
visit but are unable to due to the
feasibility of international travel go
and visit the sage Mountain Center
website I'll include a link in the
description of this video as well as the
pin comment down below but keep in mind
that this is private property so you can
only visit by appointment or reservation
only do not show up here simply call or
email Chris and Linda the wonderful
couple who owns this property and run
the sage Mountain Center that's located
on the land now I have to say that I
find this site to be particularly
fascinating and I intend to go visit
there later this summer but I cannot
honestly say one way or the other like
it could simply be totally natural a
freak of nature so to speak but part of
me when I again when I first look at it
that gut impression is like oh come on
this has to be more than just natural is
it possible that these Boulders were out
there in an ancient people in the had
lined them up together
that's a big if and that might not be
the case at all but again it's something
rare to find something new that you
haven't seen before that's so easily
accessible at least for us here in the
United States where it's a short plane
ride away and and an hour drive from the
airport uh in Bozeman Montana so that's
why it needs to be visited and explored
but I do have to say that if this site
turns out to be a long-lost ancient ruin
that would stand to change everything we
thought we knew about ancient
civilizations of North America as this
is simply not supposed to be possible
and when you think about it it would
imply that this site would potentially
be super ancient possibly formed many
many thousands of years ago or perhaps
dare I say built before this part of the
northern Rockies had even lifted and
that's a big if and maybe incredibly
unlikely but we'll never know for sure
unless we go looking and exploring to
seek answers now with that said I have a
huge announcement which is that I'm
going to be giving a live speaking event
this October 20th through the 22nd at
the 12th annual conference on procession
and ancient knowledge in Rancho Mirage
which is right outside of Palm Springs
California and I will be speaking
alongside many other fascinating authors
and researchers including Graham Hancock
Christopher Dunn Robert Edward Grant
Walter kruntenden to name just a few and
there are tickets available now on
through the website or on eventbrite.com
and I'll include links to both down
below if you would like to come rub
shoulders and bounce ideas with us at
this wonderful event but with all of
this said leave a comment and share what
your thoughts are about the sage wall is
this natural or is this man-made or a
combination of both
so all that said my name is Jimmy
corsetti my channel is called bright
Insight leave a comment like And
subscribe and stay tuned as I already
have another video in the works that
will be out real soon thanks for
watching take care everybody